in the heart of the financial World on
the floor of the New York Stock Exchange
the opening bell and a rally of the
stock market good news for the moment
[Music]
a place driven by Vibes by Risk by
Instinct and haunted by the 2008 crash
had bet that after one heck of a weekend
the chance of contagion was low
yeah I think at this point right now I
think the nervousness level has gone
down significantly I think coming into
Monday with the s p Futures Trading as
high as they were with that fear of
weight you know we're seeing an inverse
relation as to the headlines versus what
the Market's reaction is I think we've
washed out some of that but again we've
all lived this before and we're waiting
for like what is that next headline and
a week is a long time in this world a
day is a long time an hour is a long
time in this world things can pivot very
quickly as you've seen
the decision by President Biden to
guarantee all the deposits of all the
customers of the three failed Banks was
as remarkable as it was drastic broadly
it calmed nerves chairs in other
mid-sized Banks were down but then
rallied
there are many economic factors at play
here and only so many levers available
in Washington to attempt to provide
stability controlling inflation is key
and yes prices are continuing to rise
the main control lever is interest rates
officials were looking at whether to
raise them more aggressively to slow
inflation
but these Niche banks failed in part
because of interest rates they could not
cope with for Silicon Valley Bank's
customers clearly there is huge relief
from Biden's decision I'm so grateful
for the U.S government for stepping in
because small and medium-sized
businesses like ours would have no
access to Capital overnight and I feel
like we are really just swept up in this
panic in this frenzy over the last few
days when we had absolutely nothing to
do with it
all of this raises a few key questions
first was the government spooked into
its drastic action by a tech sector
which fanned fears of a systemic problem
secondly why wasn't the government
monitoring unusual Banks like this for
any potential wrongdoing third what now
for inflation interest rates maybe they
cannot come down but if they don't then
what does that mean for inflation for us
all the metaphors right themselves but
the bubble that would impact us all has
not burst the inflation bubble well
that's proving harder to pop Mark Stone
Sky News that the stock exchange in New
York